début des années 80 le département de
l'oise au nord de paris est choisi par
des promoteurs pour l'installation du
premier parc à thème français à
l'effigié des héros gaulois astérix et
obélix
nous désirions être dans une région très
très paysagère et nous avons eu la
chance de trouver un espace une
cinquantaine d'hectares où
l'implantation d'un parc n'était pas une
atteinte à l'environnement
au début du projet en 1981
plusieurs communes du département sont
pressentis pour l'installation du par
celle de base' cours en faisait partie
et là bas le projet ne faisait pas
l'unanimité certains craignaient le
déboisement des terres cette forêt est
très important sur le plan écologique
parce qu'elle relie deux ferait de
moniales très important de la région et
nous craignons que ce projet est en
effet désastreux sur
la faune locale l'invasion touristique
faisaient aussi partie des
préoccupations des riverains rassembler
en association de défense le maire de
hood encourt la commune voisine
s'opposait également à l'installation d'
astérix sur sa commune nous sommes un
petit peu les crampes il et nous tenons
pas l'argent ça dd veut le bonheur mais
la tranquillité croit que ses supérieurs
mais quelques kilomètres plus loin à
pont sainte maxence le ton change
le maire voyait surtout l' avantage
économique pour le département et
l'assurance d'un travail pour les sans
emploi de sa commune ce projet permettra
de résoudre en partie le problème grave
de chômage que nous connaissons à pont
sainte maxence
puisque nous avons près de 400
demandeurs d'emploi et qu'il y aurait
sur l'ensemble des deux projets
c'est-à-dire le complexe hôtelier de ce
que tu es et le parc de loisirs de
l'autre la création d'au moins 400
emplois permanents plus des emplois
temporaires
un avis partagé par d'autres cas rentrer
de l'argent à la caisse toujours un
second temps la ville de pont sainte
maxence ne sera pas retenu et les
communes de base' cours et/ou d'encours
rejetteront définitivement le projet
après consultation populaire
c'est à plailly dans l'oise toujours que
l'installation du parc se confirmera en
septembre 1985 les futurs emplois prévus
avec convaincu les élus pour loi ce
serait véritablement de l'oxygène en
matière d'emploi le parc astérix ouvre
ses portes au public le 30 avril 1989
depuis 200 salariés permanents y
travaillent émile saisonniers sont
embauchés chaque année
[Musique]